this is me suffering from another
anxiety attack in Dallas 24 hours after
bullet casings were picked up from the
streets I went to Dallas 24 hours before
that I was at a black lives matter
protest you would ask me how Dallas was
I could not deliver a quick summary but
I can tell you all the things that ran
through my mind because they haven't
left me instead of visiting Dallas to go
see museums and eat barbecue my hotel
sat right across the street from where
the shooting took place
I couldn't eat and I couldn't sleep so I
just did what I do best and that's film
children some who didn't understand and
unfortunately some who did and it was
not about a city divided but a city that
came together in mourning and now their
lives are stricken with fear thought
about how many anxiety attacks I had in
one week six couldn't breathe and all I
wanted to do was break I think you put a
note you know little travels a long way
and I made a homeless woman and I
thought about the last time I had cried
so I cried with her thank you just
coming together as a community that's
what we really need to do my boy drivers
became taxicab confessionals I was at
the rally some revealing how they were
in the midst of the tragedy it's been a
crazy week it has been off I didn't want
to remember Dallas for its tragedy but
even as I tried to leave Dallas the
security level was so high that it was
hard to leave Reno and even as I did all
I could think about were the people that
were left behind with pain when I got to
the airport I looked up to the news and
saw that there was a shooting in
Michigan not too far from my grandfather
and it made me think in the midst of
tragedies like Orlando Baton Rouge
Minnesota and now
where was I going to travel to next